hi dr. Wallach think you were taking my
call the research we're selling is I've
been experiencing some chest pains over
the last couple of months I've typically
physically fit in always that I know of
but I went in and was tested by a
cardiologist they found a bundle branch
blockers but they didn't find any the
heart seemed strong they did stress
tests they didn't find any artery
blockage or anything else but they
wanted to put me on a medicine called
tocrawl and I've never I don't take
medicines as a general rule I try and
stay healthy through eating I do a
number of things for for trying to build
a strong connective tissue sure stop a
minute stop a minute there's only have a
moment here so hey you were feeling just
chest pains did you have rapid heart
rate anything like that
no okay and did they give us a name
other than bundle branch block äj-- no
nobody did they proposed any reason why
that was happening no case and all their
other tests showed normal right I ain't
did you an elevated thyroid like a hyper
thyroid but that was what do you wait
what do you weigh I weigh 165 and I 510
okay any other issues have a pressure
diabetes arthritis no okay all right
well um char would you do this guy he's
got an electrical problem in his heart
okay and there's a kind of an internal
series of special muscle fibers in the
heart that spread through the heart like
roots of a tree and they carry some of
the electrical impulses around the heart
to help the heart beat in a regular
basis and so what would you do to
support healthy heart activity for this
guy Rick and he weighs 165 what would
you do for him well I would I get even
too healthy brain and heart packs but
I'd also add the glue Kodjoe
okay very good yeah to healthy brain or
heart attacks certainly I haven't take
three of those Liam twice a day because
sometimes giving a little extra slam
support the biochemical processes in the
heart muscle itself and let's see here
from the good herbs I would throw in the
heart support okay the heart support
tincture aren't supporting sure take two
doses that to dose event at a b2 the
bottles a month from the good herbs and
then what else would you put in it would
be good for the heart and circulation of
the heart cardio FX one thing you can do
cardio extra those capsules twice a day
that's particularly good when you have
heart beat issues but also how about
something like oh let's just say Z
radical let's get rid of some of the
inflammation or take two two bottles a
months of the Z radical Z like zebra -
radical take an ounce twice a day and
give us a call every two weeks certainly
give us a call every time you go to the
doctor and they give you another
evaluation but these things can turn
around fairly quickly
because in usually there's something
missing in your diet okay which results
in this this symptom so then the nice
thing is they didn't find anything no
plaque in the arteries they didn't find
any other art issues and stuff that's
all a good thing and so just keep in
touch with us and we'll walk you through
this Rick